je vais vous faire une confidence
ce serait une erreur de se préoccuper
des autres les autres ne sont que des
obstacles
se soucier de leurs états d'âme c'est se
pendre à une corde
si je n'étais préoccuper des autres je
serais morte depuis longtemps
vous avez le talent
mais avez-vous l'instinct de tueuse
c'est une question primordiale
elle croyait que le monde m'appartenait
règle aucune audace vous êtes viré
pourquoi vous parlez je crois qu'on
m'avait coupé mais ce qu'il ya de
formidable avec la justice divine c'est
qui lui arrive parfois des erreurs
quartier politiques qui ont maintenu la
vous auriez dû faire
[Musique]
saisissez là on est vite fait on sait
comment y résister dans un tel décor
comme vous le remarquerez je suis
perchée sur de hauts talons
vous appelez cruel
et
[Musique]
je veux faire beaucoup de bruit et
partant j'adore faire du prêt
c'est cruel
j'y passe souvent d'un extrême à l'autre
oui chérie c'est très amusant
elle a volé mes chiens
[Musique]
j'imagine que vous devez là
elle oblige à choisir et je choisis de
moi
rassurez-vous bien d'autres mauvaises
surprises nous attendent
[Musique]